Russia has launched a new wave of
airstrikes against Ukraine's power
plants an estimated 30 percent of the
plants are said to be damaged or
destroyed as Ukraine tries to drive back
Russian forces it has one big advantage
in its effort starlink internet
satellites provided by the Elon Musk
company SpaceX but as Holly Williams
reports that help could be in jeopardy
Elon Musk has long been a controversial
figure
but in Ukraine in March the world's
richest man won the hearts of many by
activating his starlink satellite
internet service in the country
President Vladimir zelenski even thanked
musk personally so if you'll have time
after the war you're very welcome my
invited
around 20 000 of these ground units have
been sent to Ukraine many paid for by
the U.S government musk says the
operations already cost his company
SpaceX 80 million dollars we've been so
grateful to SpaceX and the Elon Musk
without starlink uh none of our
offensives would be so successful
Lieutenant taras Beres is a spokesman
for Ukraine's military he told us
starlink is crucial for commanding
troops on the battlefield
it sounds like it's been a game changer
for Ukraine just as important as as
Rocket systems
absolutely
but then earlier this month musk tweeted
a proposal for bringing peace to Ukraine
suggesting the UN could supervise a
referendum in parts of Ukraine recently
annexed illegally by Russia
[Music]
it infuriated many ukrainians this is
this is a matter of our freedom and this
is not something we're going to discuss
with anyone including Elon Musk a senior
Ukrainian Diplomat even told Elon Musk
to get lost in salty language
and musk seemed intent on doing just
that recently saying that SpaceX could
not fund styling in Ukraine indefinitely
his company reportedly requested last
month that the Pentagon take over paying
for it
but musk has now done a U-turn tweeting
that SpaceX will continue to pay and
Ukraine's publicly praised him as one of
its top private donors but starlinks
expensive and there are still questions
over who will foot the bill going
forward for CBS Saturday morning Holly
Williams Kiev